Aloha Mahalo Mele Kalikimaka is the
thing to say I love hi everybody at
Mahalo and where everybody is right now
I hope everybody's doing well in
Paradise I'm feeling good
what's up full podcast with where'd you
go Torrance right here looking like
Hawaiian Punch
what's that brah what's up fool he says
bars are right here chillin what's up
everybody honey by doing man we're back
man Mahalo
we do know we were in Hawaii man excuse
my voice I'm a little stuffy right now
my nose is stuffed up my nose feels like
I did like our a boy each nose and
stuffy right now a man is like up it
feels like you did a bunch of blowing
your nose but then you can't find no
water to rinse it all out
yeah you do that sometimes you know like
eat - ah fulfill your like when you do
all you do a big-ass line now all of it
goes down right away seeing that I get a
bit of water and hope it go down so you
like drink through your nose you drink
water through your nose to wash down the
code yes
you also get it out of there so you
don't like you know cut into your old
membranes in your nose though yeah tools
of the trade II took the trade brah
that's how you feel like you're a better
Coker than the next guy yo I water my
[ __ ] down I do I still do I never do hey
I was gonna say I still do everything
I'd normally do bro you know like I
still go jogging bro I still eat right
it's just that I do coke if it wasn't a
while bro that's funny some somebody
should have met the net that pot you
know the neti pot the neti pot for
irrigating your nose when you have a
cold it's called a neti pot you can run
water through one nostril and it comes
out the other when you're clogged up
that neti pot you ever done that
I have one at home
what you thought I was crazy the first
time like if you give it like if you
have sinus problems or anything like
that
they sell we go look for having a save
us at any party it's a nasal irrigator
it's gonna look a little teapot bro but
it's all for your nose yet poor though
whatever it's like a saline solution so
it doesn't burn and then you just run it
through one nostril and it comes out the
other and it clears your sinuses without
any medication or anything like that
some Paula Deen's [ __ ] huh no tricks
Little House on the Prairie makes sense
though
Oh a nasal decongestant of anything a
bit damp but now and I think about it I
was like oh I didn't want to put that
[ __ ] my nose bro but I was okay to put
water through Coco my nose I know [ __ ]
his teeth water look coded a dirty sink
damn don't like pipes what's up fool man
we were Hawaii man we did out it was
crazy man we flew in at Hawaiian
Airlines comfortable seats and Rotorua
tourists cheap-ass looking like around
five thousand bottles of coke
alcohol just to with a bigger bottle
with that bottle of Jack Daniels dig if
that was a word Nana
who bought it I brought it at BevMo
before we like all kids cuz man so all
the like bag travel with your lady for
the first time i ye that's cool man it's
[ __ ] awesome
I had fun dude just loved all the love
from a Hilo dog that we got as soon as
you got there dog I was another another
version hospitality but it was cool man
chillin with lady don't that was normal
was like nothing like being at home
except here in Hawaii when we got to
Honolulu
we went to we just by the way would you
put our stuff away everyone to go eat
our food and it was nice already you
just feel it
we got laid
they put leis on us it was cool but I
never had that done before at the
airport the first time I went to Hawaii
it was like bad when their payment three
hundred three hundred fifty dollars to
do one night and then $350 to do Tacoma
so 700 bucks for both shows
back then you could smoke you can smoke
in the airports so everybody was leaving
I was waiting for somebody to lay me
then it was a black dude with yellow
teeth then that fools booking a Newport
it's at the airport mm-hmm they just
you're bad you Felipe I think yeah well
let's go
yeah no lay for you he turned a
cigarette off Oh Oscar bro you put that
in a flow to the airport and kept on it
and turn it off
that was it yeah but it was fun I saw a
lot of thing I stopped off me like
though the outside of the hotel go to
the beach I went inside the water it was
blue I went to Duke's I had a nice
buffer and and forget it and now but
this time was cool cuz yeah I was sooner
we got that the next day we had to go do
press well I had to go to press I think
I got up early in the morning every
every day I was there so we don't want
to go to press with Paul Rodriguez Hey
and that's you that she was part and I
got to be the comedian Sarah couldn't
read us who what who was now funny and
we took a flight to hello everybody
hello it was like a one-hour flight
thing total though from being in the
airport and other side like what 35
minutes in the air I don't know why I
thought we sleep I fell asleep I passed
out little tiny seats up hell yeah and
that one whole plane
where'd you go you said that the fly
went all the way up right he shut up by
the way dude mad madly steep like a
rocket
yeah man kind of like Tucson version
so we get there man that guy asked us
you know he goes what's up bruh he I'm
gonna go eat or do you want to go smoke
and after a while we do both broke so
this good takes us to the his shop and
he owes the like oh the name of the
place smoke shop in Hawaii
Irie Hawaii I mean I read away I agree
Hawaii and we gave us birch Aloha I
agree
he took us to his house and now man I
didn't know that Hawaiians were Javid
before everybody
there was it was first of all it was
super greed over there there was no tall
buildings it was all old school and you
like Japan like when you see the offer
though got dinner smashing the towns he
had those old little buildings but I
think was covered in green huh yeah
building did you see him like a like
rises up dude I got that full span it
was like a forest in the backyard um
they started raining and they stopped
yeah man
but then that fool took us to a shop
they got us a new bong a new stem yeah
but they got a hold you up gear for like
a a a brand new class or brand new
everything and then his food shows up
shut up to Jose Jonah
oh yeah and Jose Jose's other from
shoulder this pose were like Filipinos
now they were they were Native Hawaiians
I mean I don't know what their heritage
was they both say for generation three
four generations living in Hawaii Hawaii
wrong amen the food had grown [ __ ] huh
dude it was the two types of bird dude
that was cool that it was rolling up and
puffing and that fool wasn't even
dabbing though he was clapping that they
were hooking it up huh
dude the love that we received there's
like no other dog it's like for real not
even no question of like it just kept on
coming dawg it was crazy about it I also
buffet I'll take him rolling up Bloods
and I'll hit and they like the other guy
go bro world war damn
dutiful Jonah was straight they call a
slab in dog slobber dude that are
getting us in the mainland people do
dabs or they do do slobs bros abs
microscopic over here over there do that
fools dab was as big as your thumb dog
and there wasn't just any that bored
with what dude it was rosin press wax
dude that [ __ ] was like pure didn't
taste it cuz dude all right
if you smoke a lot you can tell when you
get a little bit of chemical in your
smoke that was nothing done that was all
citrusy and pure how'd you like it was
dumb it was that stuff he said it's not
the rosin press
rosin but rather pressed a straight
press the whole thing we put like the
whole quarter of weed or whatever you
have at least mash it with his hair of
your vice heavyweights and it has it
it's all heated so all the wax all the
THC comes out of the bud you baby face
alright it's all gooey it is pure Lisa
say he's down she's down for that kind
yeah because there's no bubbles in it or
anything
I don't like anything with the oil like
with real like things that a process
with butane and that sort of stuff and
there's some more options but that's a
clean and stuff I've ever puffed yeah
straight up but not only that man I put
two brought us that water oh dude
alkaline water but I'm a little a little
bowl of macadamia nuts and then cashews
with like cranberries dog it was a dude
it was a [ __ ] dog it was like mad
Hawaiian hospitality to the fullest
worse awful what's up I've got pine
trays in here but we got penetration
right here easy easy
getting a penetration yeah penetration
people what's up what's up people tell
brother people I know who don't know
about it being a gay guy gay porn
penetration sticking you from all angles
what's up fool
I remember back we used to have the
little watts of fool pins I know about
some you get happy with the key we got
the band oh yeah dude how do you guys
link up we got I saw them for the
streets yeah yeah yeah man he told me
that up
cristela loves to use one of his dub his
art I'm not sure they give a shout out
bro damn yeah it was one of Selena yeah
and then what's his name it's okay bro
you did what but what am i Joseph abhi
my let me get a shout-out either yeah so
um me and Felipe we linked up we
actually he was pitching one of his
shows out in Hollywood and then I was
having lunch right there at the veggie
grill that's right Rama uh yeah across
from amoeba yeah so we're no no we're at
the one at the Grove
oh damn yeah Fred Stoller area that's
when we met the we met Bobby Bowman for
the oh yeah so we just started talking
there and that's kind of where we linked
up and then yeah I hit him up a few
months after wanted to make a pin of him
and yeah that's how that's how it
started the whole Felipa thing that's
[ __ ] cool dog and now how long you
been doing your stuff for um two years
two years um sweet years old yeah the
pin the the pink ray started about two
and a half years ago you know batricia
people dug penetration yeah so it
started about two years ago too and now
it's just been really like saturated
with some oh yeah everybody everybody
has pins now I'm seeing more pins now
yeah so but I think for the most part
when I started um I in a band for 14
years I wasn't like in a punk rock you
started with button pins yeah so I've
always been into that style of pin and
then one of my buddies kind of linked me
to the
anam open scene and was looking for a
Cantinflas pin and confirming anything
anywhere anywhere so uh my buddy's is
just like man you should just do your
own pins you know so that's kind of
where it all started you know that was
the root of the whole thing the first
things I made I made things that I
actually was into but and then I
realized that there was nothing for the
vasa you know absolute time yeah that's
how I feel bro with a little Disneyland
man and I don't fight you eat or little
kid my father my barber devil like
always people were talking about like we
will go like you went a thousand times
now one time we have that whatever by
Dada
he decided I just spent all his money
bro I will go to everywhere bro don't
you nobody but kids Sally peers they
were bro Sally you know how to be [ __ ]
hogs
how many Brad's Richard how many Bobby's
that's a good idea though you should
come up with a new line of like kids
we're not kids nice but names that are
Spanish you know Mexican yours go yeah
bro hit they would ask above the why
you're weird
like that you never find out tamio I
have an uncle called or named IRA noodle
pho he snores huh I think so oh but I
never heard of me at his door close
you look about Louis's sound a man made
with toys
yeah but you never found any Latino
stuff bro will you buy anything go they
would never be like it's like we can't
find nothing like it you can't find
really black dolls
[Laughter]
it is yeah I mean I've always felt like
that type of stuff
buttons and stuff especially in like the
punk rock scene there was really no like
big Latino movement into it I mean there
were Latinos that were in punk rock
groups and stuff like that but nothing
that ever catered to our culture what we
grew up with you know so it was
something that I try to monopolize and I
kind of fell well I kind of feel like
I've done a pretty good job at it now
you know I kind of cornered that whole
market in that aspect of making things
you know that we grew up with you know
nostalgia stuff you know even stuff that
I grew up just seeing in school I was
mentioning to Rodrigo earlier that I was
a school teacher before we're at Vaughn
Street Elementary
bonds yeah bond or Vaughn next Heartland
Vaughn century Yeah right there in
Pacoima so I was actually uh yeah I was
I was a school teacher there so that's
where a lot of inspiration for like the
the milk carton the chocolate milk
carton pan came from that's all
elementary schools out there no I'm I do
have a lunch ticket which is actually
sold out that's a really popular one you
know I did a library card
I did a the orange juice little orange
juice box okay you know that we used to
get in the mornings stuff like that you
know that's where that inspiration came
from you know being a school teacher and
then a lot of the other stuff you know
you have the devil cart yeah you know
you see that everywhere it was funny
because when I was in San Francisco when
somebody told me that he came to LA and
he saw where I got that inspiration
because is there like on every corner
oh yeah you know and in San Francisco
they don't really have something like
that that's what I came up with an idea
one night I'm laying in my bed bro he's
about to bond and I have myself on
crumbs to my chest I got up and dusted
myself off wait a minute man I should
make her a t-shirt that looks like a
buck upon shirt you know I never seen
him before on a t-shirt yeah so that I
must hop on a bus a bun and I just
changed it to the same as a financing
Felipe sparse on it
yes and everything already out there
extra lab all those old well cuz there's
nothing like that for us huh hell no
I've never seen a my supply shirt ever
seen one after you made your shirt side
seam like do later above our design and
that's what I see with all this new
stuff - popping up is a lot of people a
lot of biters out there dogs yeah I mean
I'm from the first-come-first-serve
generation dogs stay away stop biting
dogs don't think it's tough like I said
the market has been like saturated so
and a lot of people started to see that
you know it was getting like tension you
know it was starting to steam and a lot
of people just started doing you know
Latino inspired pins as well but you
know I mean the more the merrier for me
I don't like to be that person you know
that confrontation with someone else but
I mean oh yeah our jokes
I actually did a mess up on pin that was
one of my first pins and then after some
girl did one and then I remember um I
have some wholesale accounts and some
lady was like oh I don't take that
muscle pumping cuz I have another
another designer making that one I was
like oh really you know and she just
kind of disappeared it gets hard after a
while people think it's like I'm gonna
get into the pin business and then I'm
gonna make a living out of it oh yeah
you got big stocks - they keep the
passion out of it yeah you know I mean I
do it it's like a side hustle for me
it's it's it's something that I like to
do growing up you know as teenager I did
graffiti as well you know so my
mentality coming into this was just to
get people to know who I was you know
who tagged me my tag name Tic Tac Kay
because I'm a little guy I see that you
know yeah yeah so I'm that was a
mentality I went into this you know
trying to make sure my goal is to one
day like travel to New York or travel
some
out of the states and someone wore my
pin you know that would that would be
like my famous moment you know still
hasn't happened yet
but I never went into it with the
mentality of being like oh this is gonna
make me a whole bunch of money because
it really doesn't you know it's just
something I like to do I like to get
people's feedback and but it's cool
though
it gets you out there like people not
just in pants but people take you
seriously all this kind of old G yeah
legit like that pin that you that you
have that was like the YouTube start of
oh [ __ ] it is Yahweh Yahweh I know you
guys can't see this man but this guy had
a member that video that went viral on
YouTube with a little boy and a little
chubby kid or jumping on a branch and he
keeps shaking it if you keep saying
Yahweh this will force this made a pin
how do you big pants first of all bad
yeah how do you make what is it well
it's it's soft enamel so it's a soft
enamel metal you know and it's actually
made like a metal shop I'm not sure if
you guys remember back to the high
school poetry galley I so um you would
make like a mold out of sand you know
you would put like the image into it
they would make the mold out of it and
when you take it out the mold will be
like in grades inside the sand and then
they just pour the metal into it so and
then you know it comes out then it's
actually hand-painted no no yeah they
are I don't do it myself I actually have
a buddy of mine that makes them you know
he's into that and he he's somebody that
I linked up with over the years and he
does all my pins for me so you do the
designs yeah I do all the designs yeah
cuz back in the day when you say he came
from a punk rock background it was all
like button pins but the only other ones
that were in enamel pins before that you
can get him at head shots were from
metal bands yeah I made you know
Metallica and all that [ __ ] yeah so um
yeah I just kind of put my spin I try to
use pop culture u.s. pop culture and try
to mix it in with you know Latino
Latino pop culture or things that we
were raised with like this pin right
here yeah like actually one of my buddy
told me we were at a game once at a
Kings game and then there's this guy in
the back talking and talking and talking
it's just like you shut the [ __ ] up
already you know we're trying to watch
the game and then some varieties all
yeah do you know chata he's like what
yeah you know chata who's chata shut the
[ __ ] up you know so it just crack me up
and I think dude I gotta make a pin of
that you know I made a pen and like
people loved it you know if you you know
people get that reference
oh yeah and especially if you're Latino
you know they kind of understand that
reference it'll be a cool picture bang
bro
which one for that little ass there but
basically kid actually that's appearing
that you do with a little three remember
the pig you do a little ear ight here
and I am on top of the incident or the
astronaut little football player was a
little five that's how the heard Rob Roy
he spelled boobs on the calculate it
took me back yeah bad
so before you what did you grew up at I
was born and raised in the valley San
Fernando
you know up there my whole life we're
neighbors Mission Hills yeah I live in
somewhere right now but yeah I grew up
in san fernando city we are here so
crazy a story tell us about the oh boy
whatever all right
when I care what a rehab bro all right I
like I didn't know where my kids were
they were gone you know like I went to
rehab you know and I stopped doing is
crack so my baby mama I ran off already
with somebody and I'm I stopped seeing
my kids I just hear every day I got
[ __ ] up I saw him every day you know
kid each other little smile that [ __ ]
and they go [ __ ] around I was like I was
a good dog bro
whoo look bro a bad one I would like oh
the kind of guy that were like in the
movies he gets punched all the time but
he's still there you know
so like Robert De Niro and means treaty
yeah my photo going brother
I got lost oh yeah I'm so bored Oh so I
bought a rehab on [ __ ] sober and I
met somebody and he goes April I know a
guy a girl that worked for the wall
first system yeah and if you [ __ ]
give me a name she could find your dress
damn but you gotta pay her so $100 $500
I get $100 she gave me a name of my baby
mamas name and she get the baby daddy's
name and then I told her well for a guy
but a just-in-case man if you were to
investigate this person that's not the
father of that kid the one that was just
born the real that's her brother's name
so she lied about ocation she put her
little brother as a father of the kid so
you know I give her their information he
gave me information to person one found
out with a live broaden the big 12 three
years I found out where they live in all
that bro so I thought about kidnapping
them kids right it is no it doesn't it's
not cuz it's all the thinking about I
don't even know what though if I was
gonna do they were out there I had no
plan right like you want to go see that
chain broke don't I pops oh no no I was
at the house and then I guess the kids
dad knocked on the door all crazy Oh
would you go tell the leaning on you
like that Google and you like that girl
you should hurry
would you like that girl you told me she
went to her house you spoke to her
father that you liked her and then her
you never that but I think it told me I
said but a bunch of the dad told her we
don't wanna go the data answered the
door dog but like that bleep like a
wrestler
you love the salmon you have no plan you
know you just showed up balls deep you
know yeah yeah looking do-or-die you
know whatever whatever that will you did
like this guy really decides just [ __ ]
you take out the pins right yeah nope no
idea I'm gonna happen impose you have to
do it bro you you go with it you roll go
with the flow I knew the address bro I
showed up to their house but I have
Phillip are they I could have just
dropped him off anywhere right
his mom was at work so much my Volvo was
fill up as a baby like in the back like
eight months nine months oh my god so I
was driving and I remember man I saw a
bunch of little kids and I said [ __ ]
whoever looks like me a yellow any name
I know they were and I pulled up they
weren't still more right there off the
freeway okay yeah yeah so I went over
there bro like a stalker
first of all to school right circle to
school see you know might say hello to
the gate job to maybe convince my same
my son or daughter job the gate would
take off you like draw Gerard Butler had
a plan that but I'm gonna print our fake
I was gonna plate off fake didn't I take
his bro you know whatever but I wanted
to see their man I'll ever see him a
long time right but would they would
have recognized you held on so that he
dare do so then I went to them I went to
the house and they're like so little
girl bus jumped out you know and it was
my daughter and I don't even know uh-huh
but you said hello hey she said she
didn't weigh back they said let me grab
her around you think she recognized you
probably I don't know
[Music]
I'll say I've never tried to abolish but
that was that though the last time that
was your similar story is appended to a
crime hereby grab the kid yeah
but yeah it was crazy like up I got the
how easy information is given the
[ __ ] one persistable already system
because she gave up that four hundred
dollars how much people are studying
information now you know like to leak
they bust people from the DMV
information I got this plate of this
[ __ ] or whatever and they'll give you
their address it's always a hundred
bucks it'll get you a little something
dog and that falls in with you in rehab
or you just met him after no I don't
know how I found out I think full of mob
you somebody but then I knew the guy too
it's always somebody to know somebody I
know a guy yeah bro but they know oh
[ __ ] yeah dude they look at confidential
[ __ ] all day know what [ __ ] risk my
job but that's something that you just
can't you just can't I like search you
started if you know what I find you be a
stupid I get busted they know your eyes
if you're you go wait outside brother
you could get with us that was like if
you have information that's viable for
somebody somebody gives it up no sir sir
come here man
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I got you money moves
mountains done fine get [ __ ] for you
just like you said wound up with tell
about Tiffany buddy Camacho yeah Melanie
yeah yeah Melanie Camacho was saying
that Tiffany video we had a podcast she
was talking about how great Tiffany yeah
so she she told was talking to Tiffany
about her dad because Melanie hadn't
seen her dad in a long time in 30 years
or something like that Wow and so
Tiffany was married to that guy at the
time and then she said well he's a
private investigator and he helped me
find my dad so give me his name and
we'll help you out and she's like no
it's not worth it she was like it's a
lost cause so she gave him a his name
she said in half an hour
what
half an hour he called her and she was
able to connect with her dad like he
found her so she was like I'll be
forever grateful to Tiffany for the rest
of my life because they have a
relationship now information is key yeah
a lot of those uh
p.i is a good ones or ex detectives and
all that stuff dude you gotta tap your
sources man yeah cuz usually they give
me like warrants and [ __ ] to get [ __ ]
like that so what's up paid vacation dog
for making kick ass pins so Mel how do
you usually get by looking at you bro
your sweater bro it there you're here
you just love life man like I can't
complain man I can't complain um you
should have high [ __ ] over the donors
over there about a coffee crazy it's
crazy to think you know like I have
dreadlocks you know I've had him for 17
years
never smoked in my life man never drink
I'm straight edge never never even tried
it don't even know what it's like oh
yeah it's crazy you know people always
say that you know it's by looking at you
thinking like a STONER like seemed
kidding you know he's never smoked or
his wife never done a drug ever in his
life but he's in he's in ministry you
know and he's on the road with a guy who
does all the drugs you know and drinks
you know yeah it's crazy you know like
people my band smoked drank all the time
to elves the only one that didn't yeah
so it's crazy I mean even like my
brothers now you know I always you know
I always like shoot the [ __ ] with a
whole bunch of friends and you know
they're always telling me like I still
trip you don't do it I'm like do my
brothers do it do so much of that [ __ ]
they do it for me you know so but yeah
I've never drank or smoked man how give
himself to the law I mean like everybody
I spoke to him had ever done drugs
sooner or later something happen or like
they got molested their stepsister took
them off affecting their lives they saw
their mom get beat up other dad it's a
horrible car accident
you must remember see [ __ ] dog it's
crazy that you say that cuz all the
things you mentioned I've seen
for reals booster it takes a hard I just
I'm just doing jokes here but I don't
know people that grew up in the hood
hah 'was fools that are just right there
doing horrible stuff and then somehow
they get shot this was the get shot but
II just there and then the cop pulled
him up he's think he's part of that crew
but I but they never did drugs like my
friend I said once he stopped drinking
he never drank for the rest of his life
yeah it's crazy
I mean um yeah I mean with with us
there's five boys with including me and
just my mom you know my dad passed away
when I was 15 and in and out of jail and
he was a drug addict too you know I've
seen the whole thing you know I actually
got a heroin and stuff for ya yeah I
remember um when I was about six
I still remember like it was yesterday I
walked into the garage and he was one of
his homies and he was he had overdosed
and he had a needle in his arm and I saw
it and I had to call the police
you know and um you know I've seen I've
seen pops you know you know putting work
on my mom's in front of all of us just
like straight beating their stuff like
that you know and I think that that has
affected like my brother's which is
crazy but but over your younger I have
two older and two younger so and so I'm
the middle one but I've I've always
tried to like break that stereotype you
know I there's never been like um and
it's not to say because I love my
brothers you know and you know growing
up it's like that's all we had you know
it's just my mom she had to be the the
dad and the mom so um but seeing them
grow up you know like I had my older
brother who has a drinking problem you
know and then um my brother that's a
year older and he was the one that used
to stick up for me all the time in high
school cuz I'm like the smaller one in
the family so you know someone would try
to get crazy with me and he was just
like you know pounce on fools you know
so um but you know he just actually got
out of jail you know last year you know
getting caught up in some dumb [ __ ] you
know so um they've always had that hood
mentality you know and for some reason
like I can for me it's like my mom would
always say like try her best you know
she would even say like my whole life I
I try to bring you guys in and raise you
guys in a place that there's no gang
violence or this and that but that she
just it comes with you you know it's
like it follows you so my brother's got
caught up in that kind of lifestyle
and did some time they just got out you
know so I'm like the person that my mom
has to lean on for everything you know
so I try to be that example for everyone
even my older brothers you know so I
went to college you know I graduated I
was a school teacher you know I always
try to keep my head on my shoulders you
know and try to do the positive thing
for my moms you know the worst part is
you never want to see her pass away and
think that like damn it was a waste like
my kids in do [ __ ] you know you know
well you know what up bothering you know
so you know I feel bad for my moms you
know so I always like try to be that
that little light of hope for her you
know and not to say that she doesn't
love her other kids yes you know and no
matter how [ __ ] up they either you
know she'll sit there and say yeah okay
gasps incasa's Malik a yes sir you know
so I know son it was a do so you can
solve it don't do it a little better you
know the scare of some hijos okay one
day when you have kids you understand
you know and it's like little boy yeah
you know and I love my brothers man I
mean they can't help me out financially
or whatnot but like like I said the
brother that's a year older the way he
can help me out it's like I get caught
up in some [ __ ] he'll be there he'll be
like just tell me who it is I'll [ __ ]
him up for you you know or tell me this
tell me that you know and that's just
the mentality he's always had you know
but he is the hardest worker in the
family you know like I said I was
talking to Rodrigo earlier before and I
work I work at a high-end grocery store
now you know so um I got my brothers to
work with me there now too so you know
that's the least I can do is help him
out and try to get them you know back
into society you know being caught up
you know out of Joe and it's rough for
people to get to get jobs and you know
especially when you have felonies and
[ __ ] like oh yeah
so people look at me and and it's funny
because you look at me I look like a
[ __ ] rocker stoner you know it's like
that white boy stoner and [ __ ] like that
you know Rasta man you know but I mean I
grew up in that hood mentality to I
guess I was just fortunate enough not to
not to get caught up in it
you know so I'm grateful for that man
and I do things like this you know to
try to stay positive and try to keep
those people that are positive you know
especially being a schoolteacher you
know I still see the kids at the swap
meet I go to the swap meet all the time
and kids are there you know it's like
mr. IKEA almost on us you know I talked
to the families and all this stuff you
know I want to show them that you know
there is positive things here in the
neighborhood things that we can do you
know and my goal was to be a school
teacher because I wanted to give back to
my community you know so giving back to
my community you know give doing you
know teaching them this is where I came
from to you know I go to buy to the vias
our go to you know Food For Less up
there on Hubbard and Glen Oaks said I
still see kids there all the time you
know if families you know so I do this
now just to kind of keep them positive
and this is the things that that I grew
up with and stuff like that what did you
teach it I taught elementary you know I
taught kindergarten for many years and
then I taught fourth grade but I thought
I taught you in your high as well you
know so I got a mix of everything you
know but probably uh fourth grade is
probably my favorite you know you get
those a bunch of kids that stickers I
don't care about stickers like kids in
kindergarten give them stickers they get
all excited about keep out of stairs and
they get like ah you know start
screaming and freaking you know kids and
fourth grade they're like stickers like
we're the iPads I you know you're like a
bad boy yes yeah so well yeah I taught
fourth grade for a while you know I was
I was in the school system for 16 years
and last year was my first year that I
stopped teaching you know I kind of
wanted to focus on other things you know
I do comedy improv so I wanted to focus
on that and then you know my job now
that I have and then I wanted to focus
on nice on the pins you know kind of
want to see where it takes me
um I could always go back to teaching
that's something I could always go back
to you know so it's not like something
that I gave up and I can never go back
to it and you put put it into your own
community a lot of people get the
degrees and you know start teaching then
teach somewhere else huh what deal where
I came from and [ __ ] yeah I think some
money boasters I went to San Francisco
State actually it's the first time I
ever left home you know so
shoulder was I I don't know anyone I
just went by myself like just pack my
[ __ ] up and went that was the only
school that accepted me at the time you
know I wanted to go to CSUN but they
were like the last one to to accept me
but by then I already had said yes to
San Francisco State so I went out there
for three years but I just like didn't
know anyone so I was on the grind
finished and then moved back and then
started teaching right after at the same
school that I started ta Ihnen but in LA
County though you can you can get a
higher rate of pay for working in those
inner-city schools so you know does they
have what I had I knew two teachers and
they actually called it combat pay they
didn't like one girl worked in Compton
and the other worked
she might have worked over near Boyle
Heights I think and they made a lot of
they made good money for a school
teacher I was surprised but they got
like an extra bonus because of the
neighborhood that they worked and I
guess they would to attract teachers
better teachers to those schools but
they called it combat pay you ever hear
that term I've never heard that maybe
because I was in ground zero yeah school
I taught at in the neighborhood that I
grew up in yeah maybe they were like
pulled in from somewhere else and that
was like what it was called when they
were signing signing on or something I
don't know and I know in the city of LA
or in the county there's like they rate
the schools on how dangerous they are
ten well back in the day used to be like
what Jordan walk and all those ones
right there site called good schools I
think they're known as crazy super be
more than a vegan I'm vegetarian oh yes
well you're bobbing us I bought being
and Donuts yeah I he would like you to
bust those out yeah I've been vegetarian
for four years what would be cool I
usually vegan stuff though I mean every
now and then you know I
cheese or I drink milk and stuff like
that but most of the time it's totally
vegan but yeah I I did it four years ago
and people you know my mom - she's like
give us a Camaro mr. Hollis promised
it's crazy because I'm a vegetarian but
I don't eat vegetables so like I'm a car
Batarian so who told me Hollis I was you
know stuff like that and and it's funny
because people tell me all the time it's
like Oh have you felt better since you
became vegetarian I was like man I
gained 50 pounds since I became
vegetarian me too
pastas in the bread yeah yeah I mean and
people tell me always if an animal issue
or stuff like that has nothing to do
with that just one day I was just like
I'm gonna try and just I did it and
never went back and now it's like I look
at me and me the iSchool you know like
yeah it's just like oh like I don't know
how people can do it you know and it's
you know I know one time you know I was
like you know f it I'm gonna go to
in-and-out got a double-double I
couldn't do it I was like you ordered it
and everything I have ordered and
everything I just gave it to my brother
he's like [ __ ] I'll take it you know but
yeah I can do it I couldn't do it either
it's crazy like man I couldn't do it
either man even like the doctor that I
could or would cheat on and try to do it
is the stuff that will [ __ ] me up the
most like what like if I were to eat a
hamburger without cheese I wouldn't do
nothing to my body but if that's not
what I like man I like cheese and cheese
for anybody out there with that's a
vegan well I'm vegetarian now it's gonna
start eating cheese [ __ ] that dude I
can't be a vegetarian cheese will [ __ ]
me up dairy just [ __ ] go three if I
cheat if I let go if I get a double
cheeseburger with with double cheese or
everything I will go through my system
but the Chi will just stay there bro and
I had to go back to Lamaze
nothing better push like I wanted to eat
that cannoli I gave you but now that's
not Abadi has Qi the night I would read
40 the whole plane was dubbed fool
before you start doing pins that you
would try other stuff like bottle caps
or now oh we know we saw him [ __ ]
Honolulu we never seen a long time those
pops Park pogs bro I'm coming back we
saw pogs bro that kind of swap me yeah
yeah together with a little slammer
flip over how you played for local dose
hopefully you got here man I'm Slammers
came around in 1990s right yeah pogs
yeah
they had like a little design on them
and then on the other side they were
blank and I guess you would you would
stack them depending on how many you
wanted to to like risk and then you
would hit it with the slammer and how
many popped up with the image facing you
you got to keep so that was kind of the
way the game worked you know but and
then they got really popular and they
started using like Ninja Turtles and you
know things that guys were into you know
but I started noticing they're coming
back you know maybe maybe we should
throw some Cantinflas in santa maria and
some of them pod we saw raiders pogs
yeah we have the little cylinder where
the Khadem on the cylinder feedback or
like some of the can I used to buy her
like behalf I would saved it
there we were some money cuz I remember
where now was just old man like early
1980s but these carry about that came
out in the late seventies it was like a
whole album of Elvis but uh but the
inside was like a little chocolate
alright bubblegum record but we'll go
brick yeah and they have Beatles - it
was she shaped like a little elbow and
they were all throwbacks in the inside
with a little disc it was a record and
it was bubblegum it was it was thin like
grooves and everything it was those were
great and that bubblegum was good like
it was like the big league chew
little super sauce and they had our tea
yeah it was a circle with a circle so
the grooves were that guy like she said
big dick joke but uh there was also uh
cards of the gate of the show that were
on at the time little bitty like
Charlie's Angel car trading cards penny
would know what they were worth but it
was ever there bikini or there skating
or them talking or thinking all the
shows in Three's Company a Laverne and
Shirley ice to always get the whack one
bloodbath like relax a bar Galactica
Star Trek
you know grab-bag Bush or Latino grab
bag bro yeah number grab bag the ice
cream man you stabbed him dude you don't
know what was in there brother
little whack a little helicopter usually
it was whack stuff dude I was like those
little army men with the uh but with
parachute a parachute we should do
what's a pool pin soon when we get our
new logo we're gonna do a new logo soon
talk to these two artists what's up fool
so was like growing up and stuff
Fernando brother little kid it was it
was cool man I mean like I said I had a
brother that was a year older he was
held back in first grade so we went to
school together the whole time you know
so he was like my little bodyguard or my
bigger bodyguard but yeah we grew up in
a neighborhood where you know there was
gang violence and stuff like that you
know but it was cool man I can't
complain it's kind of like what they say
you know you can be poor growing up but
you don't know cuz the way your your
your family treats you you know you
never know like those those aspects of
like what nice things are and then when
you grow up you're like damn I knit and
have gotten all the time I didn't know
this you know I have to retool this
another also at the time but I just it
was regular for us you know and it was
like you know that's just the way we
grew up you know I was like my mom was
there all the time you know she used to
clean houses she was a house cleaner I'm
growing up but it was cool man
I mean a1a for the rest of my life man
but that would just convince her that it
was bad for us whatever we wanted we
have that knowing all those bad it's my
local that's how I feel about it and
then like yeah for a skateboard for what
you could fall down break your teeth
they're gonna pay for teeth now that
people T do not pay for leg myself but L
see the future and payments of stuff
liability like we could have that
girlfriend watched you get a pregnant I
don't know what's next
yeah even just our kids will talk about
pregnancy but letter explain me how you
get there you know your person speech
about six brothers
nah never about you Rodrigo yeah they
told me where you want to get diseases
go have sex or you want to be like the
poor examples they're giving you the
right if you want to be with someone if
you really want to be with them you know
we have a fat ass cause they're like
then you will eat eat me that you would
have planet we have a finance code in
the room but you know what you just ate
is good you wanna play because it's good
you wanna be like that bad ass over
there I think your point a tweet my mom
told me anytime a guy says he loves you
he just wants to get in your pants my
entire but then you will have Bradley
what somebody did you guys get sex ed in
school yeah I was part of peer education
like I had to like I was in a small
group and then we got booked somewhere
to talk about stuff and once a week in
class and then we would it be expected
to go out and talk with our friends and
like dispel myths like you can't get
pregnant the first time you can't get
pregnant if you go with a bathroom right
after like all these myths
jumping jacks yeah like people thought
that you couldn't get pregnant in
certain ways so you just kind of try to
educate your friends like the right
facts you know when I was in high school
- he still had that driver's ed in high
school like oh we had driver's ed in
high school - yeah I don't know when
they took that out but I remember you
you you can get your like permit yeah
they took that out they said they had a
simulator
yeah I was like that you know showing
videos and then we would practice for
the test or in test like every week
stuff like that but not on the road for
real like maybe three times yeah I
remember that I was in the car with the
driver's ed teacher and some guy named
Doug for the neighborhood a bottle
it was milania's bro throw a gang sign
it's off cholo he'll follow that student
gotta be a getaway driver down bro so
that for he threw his gang up on the
back from the backseat with a teacher
bro when I was in the backseat with him
and I put throws out the big you know
the big gang sign to other drivers
you know flirt following those broad
city were going engaging a 3-pointer now
but then I saw student driver but they
let the borrowed crazy dollar teachers
are paranoid driving look forward he
goes don't look at those guys right I'll
give it a break I would get away from
all of them he's hanging up the window
or chasing you we're all lower the back
and [ __ ] like boarding stelae trying to
hide that was crazy
ah you grow up against you become an
adult you know you forget that the
classes you had but they don't have it
no more huh that you know what ending
they get rid of after I was there they
realized that I'm these shitty classes
that shouldn't be in a black
neighborhoods the Latino neighborhoods
[ __ ] metal shop bro which I learned
how to make ninja stars their metal shop
yeah but also great that man so you're
not that young
anyway so so that back then man if it
wasn't for people complaining we
wouldn't like banished our better people
sorry don't your people in the valley do
they have metal sound bro oh sure yeah I
mean if it wasn't for metal shop I don't
know I wouldn't have known how to use a
[ __ ] ruler and [ __ ] like that I mean
I learned how to do all that they're a
metal shop well we were trusted with the
arc welder bro and [ __ ] little clay
we were kids dog we're gonna train
brought to work in the mines it was that
high school yeah we I didn't have it but
I remember uh they would make a pan yeah
the pooper scooper yes first there was a
guy that was here the much older kid
with me like four years older but they
got rid of the class that he had before
I got those plastics Danno and they were
making those cooler changed on Hawaii
there was that glow uh-huh they were
caught up they were buffle bro I don't
make advance that little charm I took
that in printing class the industrial
printing you know printing press and all
that and laying in the slugs and putting
all the type backward and all that stuff
do you have that class yeah it was
another one of those industrial arts
they call it yes right
graphic cards and all we know how to
make a business card make your own star
toast fritter bro little rowdy
I bet you were just rolling it already
and then like oh my god I was just
cheated
I will get homework from the last person
I was there before that class like you
have all this [ __ ] for better Perez I
have to hate that teacher too man
mr. Perez had that little here one of
the Chicano teachers that they had this
[ __ ] curly hair but it was all in
knots inside of it here Berto Rican here
yeah it was tight but he had that Reggie
Jackson is hard here funny like that
fool down I that class I sold more shear
to students than I ever did in my life
bro D students in my class I walk into
Broadway was thriller bootlegs bro and I
get rid of all more in that class for
like five bucks each damn and that the
class where I sold my mouth brush to a
guy named account least of your dinner
will come in with what are the jacket
like it he never button here bro he was
just letting hang on his shoulders and
say what some of the counts and
therefore punch minutes older I saw that
for brush only paid like three bucks for
that okay lost boys all always good bro
and sorry [ __ ] done at these pants are
pretty shocking enough for stories Allah
teach wherever I go wherever I go if I
want to put these paints with my merch
[ __ ] the 40 bucks each bro solemn and
I'll sign them they sold out pretty
quickly when we had the fire I don't
know what your work is your illegal $40
triple my buddy this should be a Price
is Right game but for guys for people
who know how much they could get for it
I know who the winner be the guy who
gets the both pon stars no I think like
like an in living color sketch or
something like that I feel like I'm not
sure there I go again buddy bully that
maybe yeah
because it was like they were they were
actually selling you know what I didn't
know that there but the more money was
based on what really happened to them
away is because he did steal credit
cards back in the day yeah oh he was
like Tobey Hicks yeah Toby you did fake
checks fake checks what's up everybody
wish we did that Mel B checks what's up
everybody we got a couple of commercials
here hims hims hims a new one-stop shop
for hair loss skin care too sexual
wellness for men many men hate going to
the doctor hey I'm one of them
especially for more personal issues like
hair loss erectile dysfunction and I
might add ingrown toenail and of course
hemorrhoids and we're stuff covered on
your penis what if you could get these
issues addressed by real doctors but
with no waiting room to never leaving
your home one of these things man I hate
when like I go to this place and I
remember going to take a sexual trauma
these tests and everybody there look
like people that didn't want nobody to
see him either
and it was sad those guys there was a
lady holding their hands like I guess
there was a big parade how about oh gosh
she or he was caught cheated and they're
gonna be see this food caught something
it was still sad now you can't man you
can go to a doctor man fort for without
going to the doctor for hims calm for
hams calm can help Audrey go you hear
the people for hymns get access to real
doctors who can give you a surgery look
at photo video chat more in your online
consultations get access to real doctors
who can give you a survey look at photos
video chat and more in your online
consultation I'm trying to read the
people
created by doctor Esparza I'm sorry I
could I didn't have time to type it this
morning I had to handwrite it it was a
freestyle this old school do you know
what they don't do no more a medical mr.
penetration school teacher my wife was
talking about they don't teach cursive
no boy they don't they don't say that's
crazy
yeah they don't they were there was like
a week of instruction for my son in
third grade and it was toward the end of
the school year and then there was no
more and they never picked it up again
in fourth grade and I was like this is
you don't know how to you don't know
what this says and he it was sati to
this day he's not very good at it and he
made it up himself basically cuz you
think the phasing out cuz it's all
digital now because everything's on the
computer and yeah I guess people can
write in prison even it's crazy to even
like the J you know the the the way we
Stu write the capital J and then I had
the line on top they don't use that line
on top anymore either they've all gone
sans serifs just the J from the opposite
my upper set of G my father always do
the Jade like that yeah it looks like a
G yeah the bean J was no one does this J
anymore yeah it's great they do it like
this huh yeah to be a t right get access
to real doctor who can give you a survey
look at photos video chat and more in
your online consultations what that
means man the doc you could have your
doctor you could do like an online video
chat with a doctor like hey doctor look
at this and put the full rind on your
balls
and a doctor alone okay well we're left
okay that right there sorry it's just a
little more pimple you'd be buying it
let's take it good here okay
it was just badass man this mean you're
not gonna come show me things what's
this got here
[Laughter]
they cannot for real medical solutions
and real prescriptions for hair loss
erectile dysfunction and more your own
experience starting to lose a little
hair yeah I started or seen on other
people no I thought no it seemed like
you know like sometimes like Mike where
at where I started off you know in the
beginning it's like it's like going
backwards it's like going to the bank
now that's why I have long hair bad cuz
I'm gonna start covering it up you know
what am I give it a shot just see if
they can help my listeners get a trial
most of everything you need to keep your
hair for only 5 bucks today right now
while supplies last see the website for
all the details this would cost hundreds
if you went to the doctor or the
pharmacy go to for hims calm /foo that f
o r h I am s.com /foo once again okay I
can really get you got it yeah
Lori's listen to me my listeners you
know try out months of everything you
need and you know what I thought I
noticed you like my hair um Danny now
you know I could see it and I started
getting these little drops you know to
make their hair thicker I don't know how
about that works every will see those
drugs at G papa's house hey little hair
what a long route
oh my god was to me okay that she was
hilarious though well Jerry always bald
on the show there and the 90s he used to
get his hair cut by a Frank's wife and
then Frank called oh there what are you
doing I'm cutting Jerry's hair what do
you mean you couldn't Jerry there he
only has like three years but that [ __ ]
started thinning out in the nineties oh
I knew food had gray hair already high
school bro thank you to our dogs
I just genetic [ __ ] that was sort of his
dog prayer conference I had somebody I
worked with he was 22
Annie already his whole hair was a
kindness Brent Weinbach yeah there's a
lot of great Edwin - my brother my
youngest brother there's a lot of great
hair from 18 18 years old on here so
when your family have great hair I don't
know I never had my brothers did you
call that full Ric Flair bro
[Laughter]
that can happen to a lot of stress in
one shot you know I told Larry I told
bubbles Brown dies off we talked about
the last but one of our drivers were
leavin I'm lucky you Eagle Casino in
Rochester Washington he was a Native
American thank God I have blue eyes
first of all he said he was tiny and he
was a member of the tribe here I did
everything right he told me you have to
show her I don't know what I told him
but he made me show me show me like you
gotta believe him but but no one else
seen anything right when we got out
there but we'll stay mad that I'm more
Native American that guy
I'm gonna native-american that
[ __ ] man but I think don't you
have to have a genetic test and tribal
are like previous tribal affiliation
with some of your family like like I
don't know just get a card you can show
me the card I said I never heard of that
truck I know
West Coast of Washington that's where
the tribes like yeah a lot of tribes up
there they run into people to tether
native but you really show me some DNA
Cherokee no I was always told but no
seriously because my history ends on my
grandmother because she was sold as a
child so you're telling story man her
grand mother was so for a shotgun bro
yeah she was sold to a family and then
you know she debated the young boy on
that farm became my grandfather so he
was I think yes I think he probably
molested her or something he was a few
years older and then they ended up
remarried and they left she was only 15
or 16 when she married him and then she
popped out thirteen kids
well actually nine and nine kids is what
she actually had a couple died and so
but yes that's where my family history
ends but she said that my dad's father
was real biological father was not my
grandfather commands and he was Native
American and he was dark my dad is dark
skin dark hair big guy and that but she
and so he said he this is always our
story and we got the genetic test done
last year two years ago whatever it was
and zero native and my dad thought he
was not Irish at all cuz all the family
was Irish and they all like redhead
short chubby white blue eyes you know
and then we were 49 percent right Irish
49 percent in me so my dad's gotta be a
lot more I think a lot of people have
somebody tells them that our Native
American women know a lot I think a lot
of people don't really know where they
come from I was half you know and I was
like well maybe I'm a quarter I guess
then so I had no clue yeah have you guys
tried that that like Swamp Thing
1% Jewish he's 40 no 39% I think you
were roughly you had some high Native
American yeah Aryan the Iberian little I
got a beautiful is over here 1% and 2%
Pacific Islander thing Mahalo don't
worry don't worry warrior right whales
huh
what the mohrís do bra bra that big old
feet over there huh I pregnant lady feet
huh dude there was this [ __ ] cool man
yeah I was a good good time in Hawaii
I'm coming show this weekend March 9th
11th Phoenix a stand of life our shows
are so loud
Oliver man what's up with that except
for Sunday at 7 and 9:30 we just added a
second show on Sunday at 9:30 so don't
even bother showing up and try to buy
ticket like I'm gonna save you the drive
don't drive to Phoenix kind of live
Friday and Saturday and try to buy
ticket you're gonna end up doing
something else like getting drunk
outside alright but sunday is suddenly
right now you still have a chance to see
oh that 7 and 9:30
Rodrigo Torres Felipe Esparza
Tobey Higgs and Johnny rocket doing the
second show of every night Cleveland
March 15th to the 18th now you can show
up to this show man well in the
beginning of the show nobody still be
ticket left Cleveland if you show up the
show starts at 7:00 if you show up at
8:00 i'ma tell you but you can still sit
in the front
Cleveland March Cleveland at hilarities
ok if anybody knows anybody who lives
with within 2 hours of that show you're
welcome to come you got a ticket on
March 15th to the 18 that's the closest
our beat to anywhere in the Midwest so I
was like I wanna make this a road trip
and I'll guarantee you they'll be a
ticket there and they make awesome
pizzas there by the way if the only
place you order a pizza and watch the
show Los Angeles March 23rd and 24th at
the Nova Theatre in downtown LA
tickets are almost sold out I mean
they're almost sold out yeah there's
like a hundred for the first and second
shows on Friday were the first two shows
on Friday 100 left each and then
Saturday few hundred don't go fast we
just added to the show Jay Lamont I
really ever heard him the human beatbox
the human beatbox Jay Lamont Eastland of
the river
Rodrigo Torres Felipe Esparza
this show will sound loud look out for
it also a big shout out to our city
councilman Jose Huizar who never misses
the show at the Nova Theatre and have
never asked for free tickets or has
never asked to come backstage he does he
just pops up in the audience I just
created a little wife shout out to them
to us there with our city councilman of
my neighborhood love you man
thank you for everything everybody go
follow him mad at host air Huizar Jose
Huizar actually Jay Weiser
yeah he's from osaka osaka dead cause
he's actually from he was born there too
yeah I let a lot of Georgia
okay people yeah oh yeah after Texas
March 30th at the Paramount Theater I
performed there mainly many year moons
ago a big Latino show there was Carla's
Oscar Gabriel Iglesias the sketch group
forgot the name of them chisme was a big
show big Latino show and I remember man
it was [ __ ] a harder
you know house [ __ ] ridiculous heart
and how big the roaches were in a hotel
yeah man they're big and they fly
harmful you know what hit me in the
chest one time yeah skydive after
quarter soda but a huge we were across
the street from spirals with Rene Floyd
one time when we got there and we're all
puffing and what do you think that is
oh that was that she hit me in the chest
I was like I thought somebody would like
this yeah yeah baby remember being a
fluffy Jerry Glaser we stood at the Dean
of the high of the university Universal
Texas right Austin Austin yeah that guy
was a good friend of ours he'll spend
the night in his boat his place where he
lives and it was right up right on the
Main Street bought this street right
there bro right in front like he live
over top of a pizza place so that's what
we got other roaches probably wrong we
were taking turns killing them right
like every once in a while pop ah that's
it man I kill the last one now for you
gonna get this one
these ones were little one's a big one
her big bro they were big dog like like
you they don't want to smash them I will
put over the cup and throw that for the
window
Ali you LaRouche in the San Fernando huh
bro yeah like like I grew up with
roaches bro I don't want to steal a part
of my life like I was told last time I
saw roads without living with Lisa here
the manager I come on down right here
planner anyways we're a roast wrote a
poem he wrote I was sleeping I said I
said we're moving we do yeah we had to
sleep on the floor
pretty much broken loft with a cushion
on top there just seven eight years ago
we were slumming nine nine years ago we
were sleeping basically on the floor in
a one-room apartment and I was asleep on
a couch and Isaac told his friends out
in the courtyard my bed is the couch and
I was so sad
at those party I don't know why are you
know but inside I was sad and I was like
we gotta have work on moving out of here
and getting growing and building and we
did but yeah that was I can't believe it
a little kid with no legs but I / he
didn't ever think it was little bro
juice you should see my legs like
sometimes like I see it when I post up
leisa photo right next to me
people say that watching only with you
for the many years go ahead cable no not
at that place we knew we didn't have
Wi-Fi we didn't have cable
I had to go sit outside Starbucks to use
my computer my left to get Wi-Fi all
right let's wrap it up bro where can we
find these amazing badass pins people
and I'm not just saying that because
here you see me poke these up before and
right now I'm holding the best one right
here and I'm gonna frame it openly I'm a
porn I'm gonna frame and it did become
my collections man I got the pee Chee
folder bro man we're growing out man if
you do art on your PC folder hell yeah
he said oh no about that bro I never you
know our same generation I never had a
peachy 444 yeah well I had we had like
Trapper Keeper folders and stuff like
the little the guy in the back that was
running you can put a little anestis to
make him look like David Letterman how
many cholos had these folders these not
PG folder but the only folder open to
put it in pocket oh yeah man
it's a bean Chi folder it had the little
pencil like this big Adam in the grocery
store Adam
they still have to have yeah they have a
okay right so I will drop like the lame
playing tennis I will do like her
fishing I think you changed yeah and the
guys jump those guys playing football I
was through I won't make it a little
cooler that they were final world
quarter and the guys ready
I like I won't make the KKK and they'll
put the guy after all and I forgot what
the back would look like right now
track-and-field was so what's the
website is its penetration eight one
eight calm and then you you guys could
pick them up on the are my Etsy store at
penetration eight when a the Etsy store
is updated a lot more frequently so
everything that drops right away is on
the Etsy store so you can definitely get
it there promotional appears they range
from six to ten dollars
I say fifteen I think they're worth more
than stores set up for you
yeah we do have a few stores you can
pick them up at or chat area they're in
Parma and espacio 1839 Boyle Heights
you should try hitting up cuz these are
the with you in Whittier I haven't
talked to him yeah they're good they
started selling first the Dodgers shirt
with that with a design that one Tina
her story yeah I actually did talk to
her okay yeah cuz we do we do that the
other los muertos air every yeah they
have that big yeah I spoken to her
before - um and you can pick them up at
any
Latino Museum so the one right here in
downtown LA they sell them there also
they sell them in Austin at the Latino
Museum in Austin Texas
and also in Chicago I think Austin's the
biggest Latino museum in the United
States
and they have him there as well yeah I
just did a Joe Diaz one huh
no I didn't do one of my buddies did
actually oh he's good friends with him
yeah isn't there a Mexican American
Museum in Long Beach yeah we sell them
there okay never been there but I see
the signs we don't drive down a Long
Beach that much but yeah I did finally
linked up with a George Lopez I'm doing
a pin for him so it should be dropping I
think at the end of this month some
exciting stuff I have an event this this
coming Sunday yeah Richard that yeah I'm
gonna be this Sunday I'm actually gonna
be a patches and pin Expo out in Santa
Ana patches and paint Expo see that's
something merely that would you just
were to go in there and laugh all day
yeah it's free so if you guys are out
and purchase convention people we're at
this is in Santa Ana I thought this one
is at the 4th Street yeah the 4th Street
Market so this Sunday
it's from 12 to 7 and then next week
I'll be a molcajete doming ghetto and
that's in downtown right there apply
placeto Rivera they do it every every
month I'll be there next week and that
one's from 11:00 to 4:00 and then I'll
be a Chicano Park the Chicano Park
Festival in San Diego next month on the
21st
they'll be funny if you were to make one
of em gee by 2 and Shamu Rita they
should get to me guess I made like a
legend on this podcast and in life you
know he's from Harbor City harbor area
yeah he let this decorate a tattoo
artist and he's another guy bro like if
you were to see him you think this guy
the biggest dog in the whole wide world
and a cholo he never did drugs either
huh I don't think I don't think he did
family members yes tattoo that he got
the same job for 30 years it's a long
Andy but here's the biggest collection
of teenager
oh yeah so let's a troll on MySpace yeah
he has all this original prison art
Chicano art all throughout his house but
this is him like he looks like he's a
rough guy face it's got tribal tattoos
and everything but he's like a butterfly
was was so full part control coming up
no not with us the 23rd of this month in
Culver City 23rd yeah aren't you on the
show in LA is it the 20 23 24
[ __ ] guess he's telling us he's not no
I'll be there on the 23rd or the 27th
and then April 13th and that's a Toby
yep was so four big shout out to the
yeah man podcast what you got to your
vampire six episode you say that poor
soul that's more than we have on Angela
do seven drops tonight please check that
out thank you very much it's funny man I
like I will read some of the cow and
they're people writing a podcast a lot
of positive stuff a lot of people a lot
of diversity to the yoyoyoyoyo podcast
with Mikey Mourinho and hooter and shout
out to George George Perez stories
George Perez yes citing any and the
other guy Xavier Xavier and shout out to
the home in las vegas podcast
Freddie gray came out to the show
Freddie Korea thanks for being a guest
yeah thanks for the insight thanks for
the invite it wasn't wants to do with
podcast and says she said it says she
says I don't think they've done it in a
while and shout out to Michael Capone
and Honolulu for open up that gig in
Honolulu his whole family and Mariner
from Irie harmony man I've walked it up
and in Jonah and Jose man yeah man a
shout out to a Daniel who showed up bro
so when a party listener oh that's right
hell yeah dude he's a showed up at night
dude he flew in yeah he for a baby yeah
man I think he didn't leave you
Daniel Daniel yeah he said he spent $80
in Fauquier Nam and our ego rocks
organics Danny star wind daddy star wind
was sub fool and shut up - damn bro
what's up man in Hilo bro like I grew up
in the housing projects bro like you
ever run it like Pico alley so Pico
Guardian Aliso village I know the fool
there in Hilo bro from my neighborhood
like he grew up in the project I grew up
with and still talks the same way that
he liked oh people are at least a
village and you know he talks like me
he's saying fool after everything he
goes then host they're saying I have a
friend man I think he's from your
neighborhood man he sounds like you man
this was crazy he always a fool then I
steal brother and its all full from I
won't stay away from but first week but
anyway so shout out to him man he's know
what they're doing it man and change his
life bro like that guy is somebody that
needs to be like it needs to be in Hilo
forever Torres life bro too crazy to be
a nun anymore
you're nothing anybody that goes to Hilo
your life is gonna change bro you fall
in love with the place that place was
[ __ ] sweet I mean I had a dream bro
the least and I were there and she
tapped me with Felipe only live here
I've never I was chilled the [ __ ] out a
lot of places but you say you know you
don't wanna live there huh yeah I was
chilled the [ __ ] out over there dude how
was this chill dude
Oh like you know what I'll just get me a
job right here man holding this pole for
us of my life all right people we gotta
go inside out Aloha Mahalo everybody
Mahalo brah do some bro bro I got see
you later bro thank you very much
over here she said yes oh my god